foreign
[Music]
well hello everybody Welcome today to
security cost efficiency and simplicity
migrating databases to Cloud SQL
buy a show of hands to start us off how
many folks here have heard of cloud SQL
okay great
um keep your hands up if you're already
using it
still a big portion that's awesome well
so for those of you who have experience
the good news is that we're going to
talk about a lot of new things today
for those of you who are less familiar
we will still be going over some of the
basics though which is going to be a
great content
and I think it's safe to say that you're
in the right place to kind of explore
how our managed databases deliver on the
sessions title achieving stronger
security maximizing the value of your
Investments and streamlining your
operations
today I'll be presenting with my
colleague hi I'm ioff I am from product
marketing for databases at Google Cloud
and
starting at Google for first in Google
ads and for the last few years in Google
Cloud so I'm super excited for the
chance to talk to you all today
so why are we focusing on security cost
efficiency and simplicity
well we know that there's some of the
biggest challenges you're facing today
a recent survey asked leaders at 250
small and medium-sized businesses to
rate the importance of a variety of
businesses business challenges that
they're facing
eighty percent of those leaders rated
managing costs as a very important
business challenge
82 said the same about keeping their
data and applications secure and 74
agreed about maximizing the productivity
of their employees
a problem that can really be exacerbated
by outdated technology and complicated
operations
now these aren't probably very
surprising to you but they do paint a
clear picture about how important
digital transformation is to staying
competitive and being able to ultimately
overcome these challenges
and gen AI adds a brand new dimension to
this idea of digital transformation
gen AI has changed the game in a lot of
ways but those three challenges for smbs
remain really consistent
and I'm sure you're familiar with some
of the ways Janae I can improve your
operations not least because of uh the
wonderful presentations we've heard so
far this conference
from task automation to even code
generation
and we also know that there might be
some apprehension to adopting Jedi
Solutions
in recent interviews we actually
conducted with smbs three common themes
became apparent
first we heard a lot about concerns with
data security especially within the
privacy and legal constraints of each
industry
second we heard about the uncertainty
with costs with most people assuming a
hefty price tag for actually a dollar AI
Solutions
and last we did hear about concerns with
how complicated it may be to actually
adopt these Solutions and the need for
the right resources and
industry-specific use cases to get you
there
so to solve for these challenges you're
not going to make these huge Hardware
Investments and build on-prem right
we're looking to the cloud
in a session we're specifically thinking
about databases and how you run your
databases in the cloud
it's essential that your databases can
deliver on continuous availability and
high reliability
your customers expect your apps to work
around the clock and that puts a lot of
pressure on your database experts to
keep the engines of those apps the
databases running all the time
and behind the need for continuous
availability you need databases that
have security you can trust
data breaches are increasing year over
year as is the cost to remediate those
data breaches
so you need databases that can provide
real-time threat detection automated and
on-demand backups as well as auditing
authentication and encryption
next you're looking for databases that
can provide a strong level of
integration so if you're using
world-class databases with tons of data
you want to be able to generate insights
that can really power your business
you want databases that can act like a
unified data platform
with ML and AI capabilities built in
lastly you want databases that go beyond
fully managed
gone are the days of having an army of
admins or even devs working around the
clock to keep the lights on doing
configuring patching scaling themselves
the next generation of databases go
beyond they're helping devs Drive
business value and become more
intelligent about their applications
databases and how they're able to manage
the data
so that's where Google Cloud comes in
our managed database service portfolio
is designed to provide coverage while
minimizing complexity
we're in a unique position at Google
because of our Decades of first-hand
experience developing one-of-a-kind
database systems that provide massive
scalability reliability and security for
your applications from the same
underlying architecture that powers most
of our most popular products like
YouTube search and maps
10 to 20 years ago the entire Market was
relational but new types of databases
mostly the node SQL ones you see here on
the right
have gained a lot of popularity
but in the last five to ten years
relational databases have been making a
pretty serious comeback and a huge
percentage of those use cloud SQL
that's why today we're focusing on cloud
SQL our fully managed relational
database service
from our earlier discussion I know a lot
of you are using Cloud SQL already but
I'll do a quick overview for those who
are less familiar
class equal is a fully managed database
service with full compatibility for
MySQL postgresql and SQL Server
it simplifies database management and
makes it easy to set up operate and
scale your relational database
it provides Enterprise grade data
Protection security and governance and
is trusted by thousands of organizations
globally
in fact over 95 percent of Google
Cloud's top 100 customers use cloud SQL
and over 1 million gke pops connect to
Cloud SQL
it's built with devs in mind be API
first and providing application-centric
observability to your team to more
effectively monitor troubleshoot and fix
issues with your applications
okay
thanks Sarah thanks for that
introduction and uh with oh it's a
little hard to read the
the text
um so
um thanks for that and with that
introduction what we want to do is to go
over the main use cases or scenarios
that uh you might find yourself uh when
you adopt databases in the cloud and
let's uh drill down a little bit into
every one of these uh four
um for use cases so the first one is
when you do database migrations and you
basically you do what everybody calls
lift and shift where you just take
basically the database the rest of the
application stack and you just move it
to the cloud pretty much as is so we'll
talk a little bit about that the second
case is when you do what we call
database modernization so you
essentially move the application to the
cloud but you take that as an
opportunity to make some changes maybe
to replace the database with the newer
one maybe to change some code and we'll
talk a little bit about that the third
one is when you're not migrating your
application from anywhere you're just
actually building it in the cloud and
that's an opportunity to know to add gen
Ai and a lot of other things and we'll
talk a little bit about that and the
last one is when you didn't even write
the application yourself you're just
adopting an application from another
let's say a software vendor and
the application runs on one of these
databases postgres SQL Server MySQL and
you need a solution for running that
database in the cloud so we'll talk a
little bit about that so I think kind of
by definition these are really the four
scenarios is there anything that is not
on the list let me know if there's
something that's not included here I
think these are pretty much this is
pretty much an exhaustive list and we'll
try to focus more on what's new since
many of you already know Cloud SQL and
that's what we expected so we'll talk a
little bit about a little bit more about
what's new in the last year or so or
let's say since the last uh Cloud next
event
okay
um so let's start uh with database
migrations we talked about security cost
efficiency and ease of use so let's go
very quickly over these things so for
security
um obviously the first thing that uh you
would need is uh is a is encryption
across the board encryption of the data
between the application and the database
encryption of the data that we store on
disk and the option to also use your own
encryption keys if you want a higher
level of security or if you're in a
regulated industry that requires that so
all these options are available
the second thing is authentication and
authorization so basically being able to
control who has access to your data
and for that we generally recommend our
IAM cloud service for managing and you
can also use the built-in security that
exam this in each one of these database
engines and then finally logging and
auditing you can send all the logs to
the centralized log service on Google
cloud and manage and get alerts for
things that go wrong so all of these
things are much easier to do with the
manage database than if you were to just
you know install one of these databases
yourself and set all of that up and set
up the encryption and the logging and
all these things it's much easier if you
just take advantage of what we offer
here
um next uh point we wanted to bring up
is around cost efficiency so we actually
did a survey with IDC last year uh to
see uh how much people are benefiting
from moving from an identical database
engine to I mean from a database engine
to the same engine in Google Cloud so
for example people who were managing
MySQL on their own whether in the cloud
or not and then they moved to Cloud SQL
and let the product you know just do all
the administration backups and upgrades
and all of that and
um there and by the way most of the
customers in the survey were smaller and
medium businesses I think maybe all of
them except maybe one or two so this
should be pretty representative of the
results that you can expect to get so
um got some really nice numbers some of
them are here for example 246 Roi in
three years uh meaning you know if you
spend a dollar on cloud SQL then you can
expect to get to a dollar 1046 cents
back within three years so that plus the
time to uh you know until uh the break
even was 11 months and there were a
bunch of other data points in the survey
which you can just download from the
link that you see here so you know how
many databases can be managed by a
single database administrator for
example which is obviously much higher
if everything is automated so
um in the past you know one
administrator I think managed maybe 10
databases or something like that and now
it's up to dozens or hundreds of
databases per person so things you can
take into account in terms of cost
efficiency
um the other thing we wanted to mention
and this is actually the first time I'm
mentioning something which is new so we
have this these little icons at the top
um there is a new edition in case you
missed it of cloud SQL that came out we
announced it about two months ago I
think called Enterprise Plus and that is
essentially for your higher end
applications or the ones that need a
higher level of reliability and
performance so the existing Cloud SQL
that you've been using uh for all these
years is now called the Enterprise
Edition and that's just that that just
remains um as is with no changes no
change in pricing Etc
definitely that's still a good fit for a
lot of applications
um if it gives you what you need you
know you can save the money and use the
Enterprise Edition if you want a higher
level of reliability like four nines
plus performance improvements in read
and write in certain cases and longer
retention of data which you might need
for security or auditing purposes then
take a look at the Enterprise Plus
Edition so again this is an optional
upgrade for those of you who need it
um and then finally we talked a little
bit about ease of use already but I just
wanted to also highlight the ease of
migration so um our database migration
service which is a product that uh you
can use separately from cloud SQL will
basically like we called it lift and
shift your databases uh from wherever
they are can be in the cloud can be on
premises anywhere else into Cloud SQL so
it will move all your data over and then
you can cut over when the data is ready
and when the two instances are synced so
if you're doing a cloud migration take a
look at that it's free for migrations to
Cloud SQL so one one of the nicest
things is that it's completely
serverless so it manages all of the
migration resources on its own right so
if you need CPU power there's some
program that's running there and it's
copying the data over all of that is
completely serverless you don't need to
manage any resources and it doesn't cost
anything to use it
so take a look at that
and then uh uh finally on the topic of I
would say all of these things security
and ease of use and cost efficiency I
want to recommend no pun intended a
feature called Cloud SQL recommenders
which is uh built into the product and
provides various recommendations around
performance security
cost and availability so for example
it'll tell you whether you have idle
resources that are not in use you know
you have a database that hasn't been
accessed for a long time so it alerts
you to that you can shut it down if
nobody's using it it alerts you to
Performance problems and security
problems like you know really broad IP
access like you have you know you've
opened up your database to any IP
address on the on the internet probably
not what you meant so all kinds of
security things like that that you might
have missed you can get through these
recommenders some of them are in preview
some of them are released so definitely
recommend it and that's something that
again this is something that with the uh
with a managed database it's much easier
to have things like that than when you
manage databases on your own
um and then uh finally I wanted to uh
highlight
um one of our customers called songkick
who has been a cloud SQL uh customer for
a long time they've actually migrated
their databases over and um you can read
all the all the details later but
basically we're going to bring some
examples of customers that have
um and that are roughly the size of the
companies that we have here in the
audience
um okay so with that we want to move on
to the next topic which is modernization
where you are essentially
moving your database over but also
making some changes along the way so
Sarah over to you thank you yeah so the
goal here is to transition off your
legacy proprietary databases and
modernize your applications with open
source
so when you're embarking on a
heterogeneous database migration
migration of course is just half the
story because you'll have to actually
convert the database
our database migration service that
you'll have mentioned supports those
heterogeneous Oracle the postgres SQL
migrations meaning you can migrate your
Oracle workloads from anywhere to Cloud
SQL from postgresql this is a new
capability moving from preview to
General availability and assists in
modernizing your migrated workloads
this conversion enables you to reduce
your dependence on Legacy databases and
lower costs overall
you'll also be able to tap into
serverless and secure data movement and
monitoring
and although this is great there's still
a good portion of manual intervention
it's really exciting that we're in
preview actually though with new end
product capabilities of built-in code
and schema conversion
so to double click on that last point if
you look carefully here you'll see a
bunch of objects like tables and
functions here on the left in an Oracle
database that need to be converted
this of course is typically quite the
challenge because the two databases are
different
but we recently announced this new
capability currently in preview that
converts them for you this is a big step
in our modernization capabilities most
products of this kind have a less than
ideal UI and require a lot of extra
manual steps so the idea behind this
Innovation is to provide a simple easy
experience to enable your team to
modernize faster and more effectively
so if you're able to convert most of
your data what about the rest
well even fresher we just announced a
brand new gen AI capability that can
handle that for you
here we're using duet AI to look at your
Oracle functions and convert them into
postgresql
the user experience is exactly the same
as the previous feature but this is
getting us even closer to that full
conversion with Gen AI
this is a really cutting edge
development that can help you further
reduce time spent on migration and
conversion so we're really excited to
offer this new capability
okay thank you very much
um let us go into the next topic which
is
um
sorry which is uh building new
applications
um on top of Cloud SQL so
um you know the whole topic of you know
how you build applications in the cloud
and how you use a database I mean it's a
huge topic which is obviously much more
than we can come you know that we can
cover here so what we were thinking is
let's talk specifically about some of
the main themes that have been in this
at this event and we want to talk about
how you make your application data
driven
which is uh you can look at that in two
ways one is how do you use the data that
the application collects in the database
in order to make you know to give the
user interesting feedback and things you
know they need to know as part of using
the application and the other side of it
is for you as a company running the
application how you can analyze that
data and you know get business insights
into that so we thought we would focus
on those things uh specifically so let's
um let's let's start with analytics so
basically in the analytics use case uh
based you would typically have a
database such as you know my SQL
postgres SQL Server that is that is
transactional that the application is
based on and it's saving all of the data
in the database and separately from that
you might have a data warehouse such as
um you know bigquery in the case of
Google cloud and you would uh want to
kind of use data from both of them in
order to get better business insights
and provide better information to the
user so the classic example I think like
everywhere I look is always everyone
uses the same example is that on the
transactional side you have sales orders
so you know there's some application
that's putting all the sales orders into
the database so that would be in this
case on the cloud SQL side and then you
have customer data which you've analyzed
and which who are my best customers and
you know what is every customer done and
who's most likely to buy what
and things like that and that's
analytics that would be in bigquery in
this example so the question is like how
can you combine both of those data
sources to ask questions that go across
both so who of which of my best
customers has done so and so bought a
specific product so that question goes
across both data both of these data
stores right so I want to recommend two
ways to do that and some of them have
been recently updated so you can take a
look if you're building anything like
that
the first option is to use what's called
Federated queries where basically you
can run a query in bigquery that will
also look at data in Cloud SQL so you
can query across both data sources and
get a result in bigquery and then you
know continue and do your work whatever
you're analyzing in bigquery so that's
one way to do it you can find all of
that in the documentation of both
products
um the second option is to stream the
data so it's a little bit like video
streaming um so streaming in the sense
that all the changes that get made in
Cloud SQL all of those transactions get
streamed almost right away into or
almost in real time into bigquery and
now all the data is in bigquery and you
can just continue with a you know
analytical query in bigquery so then you
can run any any query that you want so
essentially like if you don't know ahead
of time what queries you're going to
want then maybe it's good to stream all
of the data so that you have it all in
one place and now you can do queries
that go across both of these types of
data so things to uh to think about in
your next project
um second thing we wanted to talk about
was gen AI so if any of you think that
you know you've come here and you
haven't heard enough about gen AI in
this conference then I can fix it now
I'm just kidding so
um a few things that are important to
know about building gen AI applications
so if you write a chat bot and you know
your first chatbot might look something
like this so by the time the chatbot
gets to the to the second question it
doesn't even remember what you asked in
the first what you what you talked about
in the first question right so uh which
uh the capital of which country because
um the models that you use for Gen AI
essentially don't have any memory so you
call them they give a result and they go
on to the next call that somebody else
might call them and you know a model
like the ones behind Bard or chat GPT or
all those um those applications they
don't remember all of the queries of all
the people who called them try to think
how much memory how much storage you
would need in order they would need in
order to do that so you as an
application writer you're writing a chat
bot you need to handle all those things
and you need to store all that data so a
database like the one we're talking the
ones we're talking about here are
perfect for that so that helps you to
provide both
um
I would so we would say three things one
is to provide relevant data so this in
this example the capital of France
doesn't change very often but if the
question was you know how many units of
whatever do you have in inventory then
you know you want to look it up in the
database right so you need to provide
accurate information to give an accurate
response the second thing is to have the
context right so the chatbot needs to
remember what you were just talking
about and you um and you also want it to
be easy to use and especially like if
you're a small business you know you
need uh or medium business you need easy
to use tools that will help you to do
that
so
um you might have heard a lot at this
event that everything
um in the uh in the in the Gen AI world
is essentially did I click too much
did accidentally click
no okay
um
we're good so uh basically
um you might have heard that in the Gen
AI world everything is stored as vectors
so all of the questions all of the
answers all of the inputs into
um into into gen AI models are stored as
vectors which you might remember like
from algebra algebra in high school so
um what was what's been added to
databases in the last uh few months and
years is the ability to store vectors to
pass these vectors along
um in Cloud SQL for postgres we
announced that a few months ago that it
supports PG Vector which is a very
popular package in postgres databases
for managing vectors so you can search
for them you can look up information you
can add information to the response
that's basically how you do the like the
layer under the chatbot in order to
store information look it up and give it
back to the model
um and wow this is the Texas is a way to
make the text like to make the slide on
the left bigger maybe because it's
a little hard to see like which slide
we're on sorry about that
um
okay
um so we want to mention one other
aspect of gen AI which is also uh being
added to our database products which is
using um duet AI as the assistant to
help you to do the develop your
development work so in Cloud SQL we
announced this was just you know a few
days ago that you will be able to use
natural language as you're developing an
application in Cloud SQL to do some of
the work to
um you know to help you with your
queries and with developing your data
model as a database developer so you can
go and say you know if you have a you
know you're building a game and you have
a list of winners in the game and you
can say you know give me the list of the
top 10 uh winners of the game and
that'll generate a SQL query and you can
put that into your application if you
don't remember the SQL syntax and things
like that and similarly it can also
update the data model so you know add a
middle name column to this table and
it'll just go and it'll do the the
operation that will go and update that
table so all of these things are coming
to duete we showed them for some
products at this event and we're adding
we're rolling them out to other
databases including Cloud SQL
and then finally Homedics another
example of a I would say medium sized
customer that has migrated to Cloud to
um sorry that is built-in application in
Cloud SQL this is not an example of a
company that uses gen AI we wouldn't say
that because it's very new but they've
been uh happy and successful uh Cloud
SQL customer for a while
okay and with that we get to our last
category Sarah back to you thank you you
have yes we're at our fourth and final
use case so this is third-party
applications we know everybody wants to
reduce the time and resources spent on
those TDS database Administration tasks
so if you're running your third party
database on SQL server for example you
need to not only deploy the application
but also deploy the database with
confidence and especially as a small to
mid-sized business you'll be more likely
to use maybe this third-party
application versus necessarily building
your own from scratch
and we want to ensure our customers have
the best experience when deploying and
using their partner solution of choice
along with our database services like
Cloud SQL
that's why it's super exciting for us to
announce Google cloud ready Cloud SQL
this Google cloud ready designation
recognizes partner products that work
well with Cloud SQL and I've met a core
set of functional and interoperability
requirements
you'll notice there is a lot of database
tool vendors on this slide if you're
currently using these tools to manage
your databases the good news is these
tools will continue to work the way you
know them too
and the idea behind this initiative is
to help our customers reduce costs
associated with product evaluation and
focus more time on modernizing your
database Solutions and applications that
will drive faster data to value for your
business
and that brings us to the end of our
presentation today thank you all again
[Applause]
thank you